for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
ok so we mentioned that light has wave
particle duality so here we're going to
talk a little bit about the wave nature
of light and we're also going to talk
about the electromagnetic spectrum so
I've drawn a few waves here got this
first one the second one and this third
one here and so what's going on with
this right that's the question we know
that light travels as a wave so one wave
we can think about it as having a
starting point and a stopping point for
each wave so what I've drawn here is one
full way from start to stop now if this
thing continues on where we have another
wave so this right here is one full wave
or one full cycle right one wave is one
cycle right so if I sort of split this
up like this right we see this wave
traveling up and then down and then back
up to its starting point started here it
goes up comes down and it gets back to
the point where it's starting again to
give another wave right so here these
are two full waves or two full cycles
here okay now remove that just a little
bit messy so there are a few
characteristics of waves that we should
know okay the first thing is that is
that this idea of wavelength wavelength
represented by this this Greek letter
lambda this is lambda oops lambda okay
the Greek letter lambda so that's the
wavelength and its measured in meters
sometimes you'll see it measured in
nanometers or angstroms but mostly
meters and nanometers at least from what
I've seen okay so what is the wavelength
well it's really the length of one full
cycle or one full wave it's exactly what
it sounds like so you could measure it
from from right here by the starting
point to the stopping point or really
the next starting point if you think
about it right that's one wavelength
that's not usually how its taught it's
usually taught in what I think is
probably the simplest matter the
distance between one crest to the next
crest so this is lambda here that is the
wavelength of this wave I use the word
crest crest is just the the peak of the
wave right the word for the for the
bottom half of the wave is called the
trough spelled TR 0 ugh so I'll just
actually spell both of those here so
that is a crest and this is a trough so
that's the wavelength there so you can
see that the wavelength for this first
wave up here is longer than the
wavelength of this one so let's call
this wavelength one and wavelength too
so wave length 1 is greater than a wave
link to you can see that it's longer
right now what about this third wave
this third wave it's actually got the
same wavelength as wavelength one so we
could call this wavelength three but
it's actually the same length as this if
I bring up that little a little bit
little these dotted lines that are going
up and down here you can see that one
full cycle of of the first wave going
from this point to this point is the
same length as from this point to this
point on this wave so they have the same
wavelength we can see that this one is
shorter for sure ok now there's another
characteristic and that is basically the
height of the wave so we can see that
here that is called the amplitude a the
amplitude so a is amplitude that's just
the height of the wave so we can see
here that this amplitude a here we get
one's about half will call that
amplitude one half of a and eight or the
amplitude spelled like this amplitude
basically refers to the brightness of
the light ok so if we have a higher
amplitude we have brighter light if we
have a smaller amplitude we have dimmer
light
okay all right let's remove those lines
because they're crazy now the another
another characteristic of a wave we want
to think about is the frequency
represented by this this Greek letter
here this is the Greek letter nu and its
measured in one over seconds four
seconds to the negative 1 which is hurts
represented by HC so one over seconds so
that just means per second right so I'll
put this here as being new
and it's got like a little curve and
then it looks kind of like a bee not a
veto okay it looks kind of like a anyway
the frequency is measured as per second
specifically it's cycles per second or
waves per second so wave per second or
cycles per second so we can see that
here if we again if we bring up these
little graph lines here this this line
here at the very bottom we see this this
is one second that the wave is
propagating through space and here two
seconds so really it's it's we're trying
to figure out the number of waves that
we see per second so how many
wavelengths we see for a second so this
first one we've got we start here from
that one green circle to the next green
circle that's one wave and that was one
second we have one wave per second or
two waves per two seconds right so the
frequency here for this first wave is
one hurts right or 1s to the negative 1
or 11 / s cycles per second the one down
here is also one cycle per second right
the third one it's got one wave in one
second so also one Hertz or one hurt
actually I'm not sure if that's right if
it's hurt anyway one hurts the second
one though we can see that we actually
have two full waves in one second so we
have we go from start up down back to
the starting position up down up back to
the starting position that's two waves
in one second or four waves in two
seconds so that has a higher frequency
to hertz so as a smaller wavelength than
this one and this one but a higher
frequency okay and we'll end up seeing
is that frequency of a wave and a
wavelength are interrelated and they if
they've multiplied them together you get
the speed of the wave speed of the wave
is equal to the wavelength times the
frequency so the the wave length is
measured basically in
meters per wave or meters per cycle or
multiplying that by frequency which is
waves per second so number of waves
cancel and we get meters per second so
now it just so happens that we're
talking about light all electromagnetic
radiation speed and a vacuum is a
constant value see it's a constant value
see and that value of C is 2.99 792 458
times 10 to the 8th meters per second so
that's a pretty gigantic number and it's
kind of messy so it's often just rounded
to three significant figures as 3.00
times 10 to the 8 meters per second so
if the speed of light is C and that
light is a wave then we can say that C
is equal to lambda nu ok this is a very
very important equation you'll see it
very often in general chemistry and also
in physics as well what's important
about this equation is that C is a
constant value so lambda times nu always
equals this constant value which means
that if if you have a high lambda or a
large wavelength then you have a small
frequency and if you have a small
wavelength you have a high frequency and
we can see that here this one has a
larger wavelength but a smaller
frequency long wavelength here with a
frequency of 1 over here shorter
wavelength or frequency of 2 so this
wavelength is actually in this
wavelength of two is actually half that
of wavelength one what's also important
is that you can solve this for
wavelength or for frequency so you can
divide both sides by by frequency or buy
it buy new to get to solve for the
wavelength so the wavelength would be
equal to C over new so this is that
equation just rearranged you can also
solve for frequency by dividing both
sides by wavelength so the frequency
would be equal to C
over lambda so do you need to memorize
all three of these no just remember
memorize this one because you can just
manipulate it to get either these
install for the variable you're looking
for in questions like this so this
example problem says a certain light has
a wavelength of 450 nanometers what's
its frequency in Hertz ok so what's its
frequency frequency is new so I'm going
to use the equation that solve for new
so it's going to be nu equals C over
lambda so C is a constant that's just
three times ten to the eighth and I
should put the sig figs but I'm not
going to because i'm a lazy three times
78 and lambda is is 450 nanometers the
issue of it but that though is that the
speed of light is already written for me
here in meters i'm going to convert the
400 nanometers to meters so that i can
cancel the meter units so i'll have 450
let's move that over a little bit
actually so we'll have 450 nanometers
and I'll set up a conversion factor here
there are 1 times 10 to the ninth
nanometers in 1 meter so that nanometers
will cancel and then I'll get 450 I'm
running out of space here let's put 450
times 10 to the negative 9 meters so
that is my wavelength alright that is my
wavelength and so I'll plug that in here
so 450 times 10 to the negative ninth
meters and then I have meters here
cancel and um if I punch this to my
calculator i get 6.67 times 10 to the 14
one over seconds right or 6.67 times 10
to the 14th hurts that is my answer so
you have a lot of different problems
like this that's a 14 it looks like a 19
now that I've boxed it it's kind of
changed that make it look a little bit
prettier so we got the 14th there so
there are a lot of problems that are
like this just be sure that you can
manipulate this equation and solve
problems like that
next up is the electromagnetic spectrum
okay so that we can see here so at the
top here we've got wavelengths in meters
and frequencies in Hertz so you can see
that going from left to right we've got
small wavelengths here as increasing
this way so we're going increasing
wavelengths this way and as the
wavelength increases what's happening to
these frequencies they're getting
smaller so we're having decreasing
frequencies so what are the different
types of electron my tend to create
radiation in the spectrum over here
we've got gamma rays in this range we've
got x-rays over here ultraviolet rays
here we've got infrared rays or ir over
here we've got microwaves right over
here at radio waves over here at this
end okay now in this tiny little section
here we've got the visible spectrum
that's the part of the spectrum of light
that we can actually see it's a really
really small relative to the overall
spectrum right we can see though that
this visible portion is actually within
or specifically the range of 400
nanometers to 750 nanometers and we see
that this is the colors of the rainbow
right we know them as ROYGBIV but since
I've written it here as from you know
from lowest wavelengths the highest
wavelength it's viv gee you're anyway
the point is that says the backwards
here but you probably learned maybe
maybe not that clubs the rainbow or
roygbiv red orange yellow green blue
indigo violet so near the 400 n 2 400 n
a meter end we've got violet light and
we've got up to the 700 750 s where the
red is okay so red had red light has a
longer wavelength and thus a shorter
frequency and violet light has a smaller
wavelength
and a a larger frequency so now I do
have some turn terms down here that are
just for your information if you hear
the term monochromatic when referring to
light it's speaking about light of one
wavelength whereas we hear polychromatic
it's referring to light of many
wavelengths it's just terms that you
might might hear so one question that
comes up a lot when we're talking about
the electromagnetic spectrum is what's
going on with the energy the different
types of electromagnetic radiation now
that's something that we're going to
kind of address in the next video but I
will kind of comment on something here
we kind of we we listen to the radio in
our cars and there are radio waves all
over the place and they're actually
pretty low in energy they're not harmful
to us right but as you kind of move your
way over to the left especially when you
think about ultraviolet rays they can
call it sunburns x-rays they can do
damage to your body that can cause some
mutations in your DNA for instance and
gamma rays are just super high in energy
so we've got to the left over here these
really tiny wavelengths and high
frequencies we've got high energy rays
on this side and over here to the right
where we have smaller or maybe we may
have larger wavelengths but smaller
frequencies you've got lower energy
right and this is something that you
should keep in mind when you watch the
next video so I hope this video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying